keep along
and then uh the request
we all saw the news yesterday
from the city kitarian uh asylum
the announcement that he is 12,000
needs extra shelter places for asylum seekers
to my surprise,
last time the PVV
the committee debate canceled
making the first coming bath pass
scheduled for June
close empties my uh fraction
1 proposal to keep that 1 planned bath
the marcusa though
yes then you are going to hear it so big word
but Mrs.
Pirrie of course wants uh
thank the State Secretary again for that red
carpet for all those asylum seekers
and uh so uh she can do that tomorrow
in 1 debate that is also about receiving asylum if she wants to
she can involve that in me
it is 1 competition law to submit
so then you can go that long
as much as possible interromp what you want
let's get involved there
then we can talk about it tomorrow
broken to the core
yes chairman
this is of course very strange what is happening here
I don't think we should want to
we just need to have 1 in the bath what it's about
and if the PVV itself uh
uh meetings canceled
yes then they should not beep here
so I think support for this uh
for this request
because I think it's really good to be here uh
to talk to each other about it
the bridge around our stone
wife emperor untenable situation chairman
financial legal
social and so on
so talk about that without solutions from the p v
a makes no sense to me
no support it costs something
support the curl
well chairman
I wouldn't want the suggestion to work here anyway
that PVV can cancel meetings
we just got the prostitutes
who have to go through all the vaccisions
so that's really something I don't think is right
no support for this debate
Field camp
support for this of postures 1
I hear that special
I still establish chairman
I think we know Mr.
Gidi Mark
we would all be weekly from here
for 1 debate for action and migration
and now they want to
just don't even take over the debates anymore
then we should marken would respond
very short tomorrow
I just stand
where you are now and can you interromp me
until you weigh in us
and then we can just talk about it
nothing has been canceled
there are about every month
very well we are going to listen to the Lord dike of the s
p no
you sit down in the members restaurant
at my expense
are you going to fight the rest of the day because
it drives me crazy
okay you can go on
you may respond to the allegation
very short very short
tomorrow there is 1 debate
1 game went from the Aliens Act
has nothing to do with yesterday's announcement
from the city